c'est vrai qu'à 18 ans vous étiez le
dernier puceau de la pension oui c'est
vrai que j'étais plutôt très tard
j'ai fait un peu chier de dire
voici Benoît Poelvoorde
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS bonsoir
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est plus difficile de faire la
promo que de faire le film non c'est
plus parfois plus long
incroyable je vous ai vu partout non pas
partout avec quelques endroits où je ne
suis pas allé oui vous n'êtes pas allé
chez Fogiel c'est vrai c'est vrai vous
voyez comme je suis fidèle à votre
travail
en tous les cas le film est un succès
considérable je crois que c'est le
deuxième meilleur démarrage de l'année
non oui c'est vrai
on a fêté ça moi j'attendais que ce soit
un succès pour vous inviter en fait oui
je sais je suis comme ça il sera cool
décontracté alors là vous êtes plus
obligé de bosser laissez-vous aller
complètement là
en tous les cas donc je vais quand même
vous présenter comme si vous étiez là
comme si vous étiez dans cette émission
voilà donc vous avez 37 ans
vous êtes belge comédien scénariste on
vous a vu dans cette arrivée près de
chez vous dans les randonneurs dans les
convoyeurs attentes dans les portes de
la gloire dans le vélo de Ghislain
Lambert et aujourd'hui donc dans le
boulet voilà vous avez fait de la scène
aussi avec modèle déposé
vous avez fait de la télé avec les
carnets de Monsieur Manhattan sur Canal+
et vous avez eu le prix Jean Gabin 2002
mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup c'est comment on fait
avec les petites mains oui oui
madame monsieur
[Musique]
alors le boulet donc un film produit par
Thomas Langman réalisé par Alain
Berberian et Frédéric forestier avec
vous c'est un petit peu pour ça que vous
êtes là en même temps et Gérard Lanvin
et Gérard Darmon et José Garcia et voici
de Palma et Jean Benguigui alors c'est
ce qu'on appelle un body movie c'est ce
qu'on appelle un film de couple
basé sur un tandem de mec il y avait eu
par exemple l'emmerdeur avec une
auventura et Jacques Brel la chèvre avec
Depardieu et Pierre Richard La grande
vadrouille avec Bourvil
alors le couple fonctionne très très
bien et
le coup fonctionne bien avec Lambin non
ah oui oui vraiment bien mais on s'est
bien entendu on pouvait pas faire le
film si on s'entendait pas c'était il
fallait s'amuser c'est un film pour
s'amuser il fallait le faire en
s'amusant on s'est bien amusé à le faire
on s'est bien amusé à le tourner on
s'est bien amusé à le présenter à le
proposer au public on sait jamais tout
le temps alors donc je fais le pitch je
voulais que je fasse le pitch
alors donc Lanvin c'est un truand c'est
même un assassin il est en tôle et il
est gardé par un maton qui est joué par
vous un petit chez Fayon là comme fête
si bien et un jour il joue au loto
quelques quelques jours avant ça ça qui
gagne mais c'est votre femme qui allait
acheter le ticket elle l'a gardé et
malheureusement votre femme qui est
jouée par Rossi de Palma par comme
infirmière sur un rallye en Afrique
voilà après il y a plein d'aventures
évidemment que je vous laisse découvrir
chers amis téléspectateurs dans un
cinéma près de chez vous voilà et vous
passez votre temps comme ça vous courez
après Garcia qui vous poursuit et il y a
un super méchant qui interprété par José
Garcia et franchement je suis pas très
nul
impressionnant est-ce que c'est vraiment
de la bande dessinée filmée donc il
fallait qu'il soit crédible c'est du
premier degré il fallait qu'il soit
méchant méchant et il est méchant
méchant et malgré ça ça très petite il a
mis pour laisser pousser les cheveux oh
je l'ignore mais comme il est tout de
même de nationalité espagnole ça n'a pas
dû être bien long donc Benoît
alternance
de scène de comédie et de scène à grand
spectacle il y a évidemment tout un jeu
entre vous deux une grande complicité
effectivement et puis et puis aussi des
scènes très spectaculaires comme par
exemple la grande roue de Paris
sur les Tuileries et oui c'est
extrêmement impression parce que nous
quand on l'a vu dans le scénario c'est
facile à écrire de dire que la grande
roue va se décrocher qu'elle va elle va
aller dans toutes les Tuileries écrit ça
prend cinq lignes après il faut tourner
donc nous en tant qu'acteur on s'est dit
si jamais c'est fait par des par des
bras cassés on va avoir l'air d'une
solide bande de tâcherons donc nous
quand on l'a vu on était vraiment
vraiment très très impressionné là genre
hommage à Frédéric forestier qui a fait
un boulot de c'est très très bien il est
tout jeune Fred et vraiment il est il
est parti
une carrière américaine dirions-nous
c'est français je trouve ça vraiment
très très impressionnant
j'ai la France
donc tournage assez éprouvant j'ai passé
deux mois dans leur classe au bord de la
piscine de l'hôtel
j'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent j'ai gagné
raisonnablement ou j'ai gagné ma vie sur
ce film c'est vrai c'est vrai
franchement vous dites
le film de marche pas là
fonctionne très très bien alors que j'ai
pas de honte à avoir quand le film ne
marche pas vous vous tapez quand même
deux trois mois de honte grâce et après
vous en faites un
[Rires]
alors
c'est d'autant plus cher que vous ne
vous trouvez pas bon acteur
vous dites un jour ils vont s'en rendre
compte ils vont me demander de
rembourser oui j'ai toujours
l'impression qu'on va me dire on s'est
trompé il va falloir tout rendre le
nouveau Bourvil
ça ça fait plaisir ah non non je suis
très très flatté mais
je suis moi
justement on va parler de votre vie
[Musique]
alors vous êtes né Benoît à Namur en
Belgique dans une famille relativement
modeste un frère une sœur un frère une
sœur très simple très classique vos
parents se sont séparés quand vous aviez
5 ans et vous êtes retrouvé un terme
pratiquement dès l'âge de 7-8 ans on
pense pas très drôle vous dites que vous
avez jamais connu Noël en famille non
c'est vrai parce que j'étais tout le
temps dans les internats où les
colonies de vacances ou les oui oui
c'est vrai j'ai jamais fêté Noël en
famille mais enfin c'est pas très drôle
si on l'a regardé si on la lisait comme
vous la lisez sur le papier ça peut
paraître tragique mais moi je me suis
fait beaucoup j'ai une enfance
magnifique enfin moi je trouve qu'elle
était magnifique votre père criait
beaucoup quand même mon père criait
beaucoup mais c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un
d'assez bourru c'est un routier il
savait pas dire je t'aime il y a des
gens comme ça oui oui c'est vrai oui oui
enfin bon
comment dirais
c'est délicat de dire ces choses là je
pense que je crois qu'il y a des gens
qui l'expriment différemment oui c'est
vrai n'hésitez pas pardon c'est pas son
genre quoi il était pas quelqu'un de
très expansif non t'es pas très
expertise j'en ai pas enfin
en fait dès l'âge de 17 ans vous êtes
autonome vous prenez un appartement
au-dessus du magasin de votre mère en
même temps
c'est assez libéral c'est sympa c'est
cool j'ai beaucoup de chance et alors
s'ensuit une longue période d'hésitation
entre les études et le travail
vous savez pas vraiment quoi faire
surtout j'avais envie de rien faire du
tout c'est très heureux à l'école même
en échouant je suis très heureux dans
les endroits où il y avait beaucoup de
gens et alors dans l'année de vos 18 ans
vous avez comme mission de réaliser une
affiche pour un spectacle de théâtre
local vous êtes bien renseigné à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
bon merci les enfants non donc voilà
vous devez réaliser cette affiche pour
un théâtre local et puis comme l'acteur
a eu un accident oui
c'est parce que je voulais rencontrer la
une jeune fille qui se trouvait dans la
classe qui jouait dans cette pièce de
théâtre en fait j'ai fait du théâtre et
du cinéma uniquement pour rencontrer
cette fille qui était dans la classe à
côté que je n'ai pas pu rencontrer en
faisant la fiche parce qu'elle en avait
rien à [ __ ] le mec qui faisait la
fiche donc après donc vous faites de
petits rôles dans de petits films avec
votre pote Rémi Belvaux vous continuez
le dessin à Saint Luc à Bruxelles qui
est une école fameuse pour la pour la
bande dessinée et c'est comme ça que
naîtra ce film culte d'une génération
c'est arrivé près de chez vous coécris
par vous avec Rémi Belvaux et André
bonzel il y avait beaucoup d'amour dans
ce film
basé là-dessus et je ris en voyant
l'extrait parce que quand vous voyez le
livre qui tombe le petit morceau dessus
qu'on a mis dans le dans le verre André
bonzel le chef hop il a passé des
semaines à filmer dans son appartement
c'est stupide plan de coupe de sucre il
n'y arrive pas c'était la seule
puisqu'on avait pas de matos et tout et
après chaque weekend il voulait lui dire
je crois que cette fois je suis arrivé
j'y suis ensuite il y a eu les
randonneurs donc vous êtes excellent et
puis toujours ce rôle un petit peu dans
les randonneurs on retrouve dans le
boulet ce rôle de chez Fayant un peu
quand même c'est quelque chose je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai un physique qui prête
au petit chef au petit bonhomme qui se
cache derrière l'autorité ouais je sais
il y a un truc que je comprends pas chez
vous si vous parlez sans arrêt de votre
physique en vous dénigrant vous dites à
17 ans j'avais déjà une tête de vieux
j'ai deux jours peut-être de vieux donc
je n'invente quand il le verront à la
télé ils vont rire ils vont dire oui
c'est vrai on a fait la tête de vieux
c'est vrai qu'à 18 ans vous étiez le
dernier puceau de la pension ah oui
c'est vrai que j'étais plutôt très tard
j'ai fait un peu chier de dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc Benoît vous avez fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'interviews ces dernières
semaines vous êtes un petit peu voilà
vous avez peut-être un petit peu marre
donc on va faire une interview sans
intérêt
aucune difficulté
[Musique]
bagnoles Thierry vous le savez et je
suis très gêné d'avoir une vilaine
couleur pour ma voiture
t'as pas vu ma perceuse là je n'ai pas
vu sa perceuse non
non non non
vous préférez les chiens ou les chats
les chats j'adore les chats
tu dors bien en ce moment je n'ai jamais
bien dormi
je dormirai bien mon repos final
[Rires]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu